[Musique]
ARN deange bonjour bonjour vous êtes là
en tant que qu'ancien versaillais vous
êtes né vous avez vécu au chînet vous
avez bien connu cette salle du Tyrano
enfin celle-là et les autres tout les
autres je les ai toutes faites et toutes
les autres voilà donc on revient un peu
sur les les lieux de votre enfance pour
justement il y a pas de hasard c'est
fait complètement exprès pour parler de
cinéma justement parce que vous avez
beaucoup de cordes à votre arc et là
c'est une nouvelle nouvelle facette de
vous qui s'exprime qui tente tente tente
mais qui réussit apparemment donc vous
venez de sortir un courtmétrage ouais un
un racontez-nous alors ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle Bing Homer Simpson ça raconte
l'histoire de Philippe pétiieux qui est
le doubleur d'Omer Simpson officiel qui
est marié dans la vie à Véronique ogero
qui fait marge ah pour de vrai c'est un
vrai couple à la vie comme à la scène
c'est le deuxième couple de l'histoire
du dessin animé à faire ça les premiers
c'était Mik et mini aux États-Unis dans
les années 60 c'est marrant et là c'est
le deuxè et ça fait longtemps qu'ils le
font d'ailleurs oui ça fait 25 ans ouais
c'est ça et donc je raconte l'histoire
de ce couple qui se retrouve un jour
confrontter un fan fou joué par Arnaud
de sa mère qui a des pouvoirs psychiques
et qui oblige un jour Philippe pu à ne
plus parler autrement qu'avec la voix de
mère ce qui complique singulièrement la
vie bah oui on imagine toutes les
conséquences voilà et ça ça le rend
malade d'accord donc ça c'est un on dit
un courtmétrage qui qui du 20 minutesou
c'est un film de 20 minutes en fait
c'est enfin moi qui eu la chance de le
voir c'est un peut dire un miniilm tous
les un film petit format mais le le le
le terme de courtmétrage il a été pas
mal galvodé parce que je trouve que
c'est des des c'est des beaux petits
objets ça a la même valeur qu'un film on
se raconter une véritable histoire en 2
minutes ouis il y a un début un milieu
une fin il y a des vrais actur viend ça
viendrait à personne de l'idée de dire
que bref c'est des court-métrages bref
c'est une œuvre en soi les gens disent
j'ai regardé bref ils disent pas j'ai
regardé un courtmétrage un peu marrant
d'une minute 30 parce que là ça fait
pourri mais voilà le le vocable il a été
un peu dévalué mais le le le vrai sens à
la base c'est euh c'est petit film
histoire alors c'est sûr qu'on n pas les
moyens techniques financiers et alors
comment vous êtes produit justement en
parlant de ça oh ben je me suis produit
avec mon mon compte courant auto produit
avec mon compte chèque à la BNP d'ord
donc non non c'est c'est c'est produit
soi-même en fait le le les réseaux
sociaux ont beaucoup joué quand même oui
alors c'est visible sur daily motion
c'est visible sur daily motion ça a été
énormément partagé sur sur Facebook sur
Twitter c'est sorti quand c'est sorti le
le 20 juin je crois 19 juin et en en une
semaine on a fait 300 350000 vues 350000
vues qui est juste énorme ouais ouais ça
ça pour un 20 minutes c'est gros c'est
vraiment gros parce que les gens
décrochent quand même normalement au
bout de 3 minutitude sur Internet les
gens n'ont pas l'habitude enfin
l'habitude de l'habitude de l'habitude
de rester si longtemps devant un écran
c'est ça que vous voulez dire enin sur
une vidéo en tout cas sur une vidéo il
décroche au bout de 3 minutes en moyenne
et là il se le refil statistiquement on
le voit en moi j'ai des données magiques
il se le refile et les gens vont au bout
donc ça veut dire que ça fonctionne
c'est tout le monde est pris ouaisonde
dou ce buzz phénoménal ouais ça marche
ça marche vraiment bien et c'est c'est
relayé par la presse et cetera non non
ça vous AZ une bonne critique très bonne
ouais ouais ce que je m'explique même
presque pas puisque techniquement voilà
comme il y avait pas de moyen pas de
lumière pas de pas de temps pour le
faire et et que ça a été fait sur mon
temps libre les soires et les weekends
oui d'accord vous avez tourné en combien
temps est-ce que vous AZ portter plainte
5 6 jours céit 5 6 jours de tournage
c'est assez ça va pour la matière c'est
c'est suffisant mais c'est très peu de
répète c'est fait à l'arrache et puis
surtout on n pas le droit de se planter
c'est-à-dire que en une journée faut
faire ce qu'on s'était dit dans la
journée on n pas le confort de de
repousser au lendemain si jamais on a
pas eu le temps donc tout a été fait
dans la précipitation et de manière un
peu entassée donc ça se voit mais en
même temps on se rend compte que les
gens quand on leur raconte une bonne
histoire peu importe le la la le
matériel technique oui on oublie voilà
ils sont accrochés par l'histoire le et
pmotion par vous vous êtes humoriste à
la base enfin vous êtes connu pour ça
bon c'est sûr que c'est drôle mais il y
a aussi finalement des moments assez
émouvants même un peu TR ouais il y a
une tendresse pour pour le personnage
voilà oui on comment dire on a un peu
mal au cœur pour lui quand il se
retrouve coincé avec cette voix enfin
c'est pas c'est vrai que c'est ridicule
il se retrouve avec une voix de dessin
animé qui est ultra comique et que tout
le monde connaît il doit il doit parfois
dire des choses sérieuses et vivre avec
ça et
et avoir une vie comme tout le monde
mais on est dans la même gne que je sais
pas moi qu quand on voit un chien avec
une cerette par exemp c'est horrible
mais c'est horrible mais en même temps
c'est super drôle
ou quand on voit quelqu'un tomber dans
la rue ouais on a mal pour lui mais en
même temps il s Varé c'est marrantou et
on est toujours dans cette ambivalence
avec ce personnage qui a cette voix
ridicule et qui en même
temps en même temps c'est quand même
drôle c'est vrai les acteurs sont
formidables ils avaient pardon ils avent
déjà joué autrement que de leur voix
comme alors les comédiens de doublage
font beaucoup de théâtre ou en ont
beaucoup fait sont des acteurs de
théâtre ouais principalement d'accord
très peu de cinéma parce que le le le
fait d'être prisonnier de leur voie leur
a fermé pas mal de portes par exemple
l'acteur qui fait Bruce Willis Patrick
Poivet c'est un acteur vraiment
formidable il y a une présence à l'écran
qui est incroyable c'est Jean Gabin et
le problème c'est que on lui a dit bah
oui mais tu as la voix de Bruce Willis
donc ça passe plus et alors que c'est
c'est un un type vraiment extraordinaire
en en charisme enfin il porte les choses
merveilleusement bien et ils sont
nombreux dans ce cas-là et c'était un
moyen aussi de rendre hommage à toute
cette cette famille de de de comédiens
qui a pas
eu la carrière qu'elle méritait c'est
qu'on choisit une voix un peu plus
étroite ouais et c'est c'est d'autant
plus dommage que je les trouve même
meilleur en en comédie que certains
acteurs français estce que eux ayant été
bibronnés euh en en doublant des gens
qui ont l'habitude de jouer des
magiciens des extraterrestres des
savants bah ils nous racontent autre
chose dans leur dans leur histoire que
des histoires de voisins de palier comme
on a avec Vincent lindan ou Jean-Pierre
Bacri ont finalement des registres de de
jeux beaucoup plus réduits plus étroit
en tout cas s'ils sont plus étendus on
le voit jamais là les comédiens de
doublage ils ont au moins VO le tê ils
peuvent tout faire ils peuvent tout
faire donc ils savent qu'il peuvent tout
faire plus l ou ils ont plus de
confiance on plus d'périencep ils ils
ont plus d'expérience ils ont plus de
confiance dans ce qu'ils peuvent faire
quand on leur amène un rôle un peu F
trac ils disent pas non ça fait pas peur
et euh et ils ont pas peur du paranormal
de la science-fiction de l'horreur du du
comicque même y a plein d'acteurs qui
ont peur du comic c'est quand même fouon
et et eux ils vont avec bonheur donc
c'est un vrai plaisir de travailler avec
eux et je pense en plus qu'ils sont
presque meilleurs que beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de comédiens catégorie d'acteur
qui n pas assez utiliséou ouais vraiment
bah apparemment de toute façon ça
fonctionne super bien vu le succès de de
votre film et euh quel est quel est le
la suite de ce projet moi j'aimerais le
transformer en longmétrage j'ai des
touches ou d'accord euh donc ça pourrait
se faire après je connais trop ce métier
et je sais que quand rien est
signé enfin quand rien n diffusé
d'ailleurs hein tant qu'un truc n'est
pas diffusé il existe pas donc je vais
pas tirer de plan sur la comète enfin il
y a déjà une un intérêt pour l'idée et
et pour l'univers du doublage je pense
que là aussi ça ça a mis un coup de
projecteur nécessaire sur famille pas
bien ouais de comédiens qu'on connait
pas et qui en même temps est est très
familier aux oreilles du public puisque
on le voit dans le film oui là j'ai
organiser une pe projot avec plein de
comédiens de doublage qui étaient là et
les gens avaient l'impression de passer
la soirée à Hollywood parce que ils
entendaient à côté d'eux il y avait
Bruce Willis samuelel Jackson Jamy Lee
Curtis et et plein de voix de dessins
animés qu'ils avaient de leur enfance et
d'un seul coup bah c'est c'est s'animent
et qui prenaient corpsoua ça ça ça donne
une une réalité et et et en même temps
on est dans le rêve tout de suite
puisque c'est des alors c'est tout
l'ambivalence de ça he c'est c'est tout
le problème c'est pourquoi on les
utilise pas au cinéma c'est parce qu'il
rappelle d'autres gens mais mais là
c'est utilisé à essan voilà au moins
c'est au service de l'idée générale donc
ça fonctionne et les gens et ça faisait
longtemps que vous aviez envie de de
réaliser oui parce que j'adore le
doublage vraiment vrai ouais ouais ouais
moi mes meses mes premières émotions
humoristiques c'est c'est ce que faisait
Jacques Balutin et Francis LAX dans dans
Starski h je sentais bien qu'il
déconnait avec les personnages ah vous
AZ une vrai passion pour ce cet univers
à la base
moi mon entrée dans la sensité la voix
de michelx bien avant les coco girls
j'avais 4 ans et je trouv déjà ça super
joli et j'avais un petit tmoi en
entendant Micheline Dax donc c'est vous
dire que puis en plus elle doublait pigy
la donc il y avait un
truc ce que vous disiez c'est qu'ils ont
des palettes super larges très larges et
puis voilà elle elle avait elle un
glamour dans la voix que plein
d'actrices n'ont pas elle a cette espèce
de voix ROG de vieille enfin
c'est incroyable elle a elle a un vrai
truc mais je pense qu'elle le revendique
un peu mais ouais et euh j'étais
vraiment vraiment fan de doublage je
me'y suis toujours intéressé je voilà il
y a les bonnes VF et les mauvaises VF
mais il y a plein de films des années 80
qui sont nettement meilleurs en VF qu'en
VO parce que en VO c'est fuck fuck fuck
et en VF c'est il y en a RAL melon
couill mol et d'un seul coup voilà il y
a du odudiar là où il y en a pas dans la
version originale ah oui donc en fait
avec le la traduction est plus
intéressante oui parce que c ces gens-là
ont été élevés aux années 60 et aux
phrasé du du et aux années 50 et donc
tout le truc du titi parisien qu'ils ont
remis euh sur voilà qu'ils ont calqué
sur la version originale et donc elle
s'enrichit ouais et elle s'enrichit
d'une d'une matière littéraire qu'elle a
pas au départ et et ça se complète bien
quand même avec la matière moderne de
venue des États-Unis donc il y avait un
vrai truc à cette époque- là euh du fait
de l'éducation des comédiens américains
qui était pas du tout la même que celle
de des comédiens doubleage c'était pas
la même culture et ça se télescopait
remarquablement bien c'est pour ça que
j'adore ça d'accord et donc vous avez eu
cette idée bah l'idée la volonté de leur
rendre hommage en tout cas déjà et après
vous avez trouvé cette idée pour pour
faire ce ce film voilà ce film qui
d'accord vous avez mis combien de temps
à le alors l'idée je l'ai eu il y a 2
ans entre le l'idée et la diffusion il
s'est coulé 2 ans d'accord parce qu'il
faut le préparer il faut trouver un
créneau comme tout le monde travaille
gratuitementz scénario ça été vite en
une semaine c'était bouclé mais après
c'est la prépa faut trouver une des
dates communes pour tout le monde tout
le monde travaille gratuitement et fait
autre chose à côté doncou faut là ça a
été compliqué et puis après le montage
c'est pareil on est tous très occupés
enfin moi j'écris quand même pour deux
quotidiennes je fais quelou sur Europe 1
et quelou sur TF1 c'est du boulot euh
donc rien que ça ça prend du temps et
après il y a tous les trucs que je fais
à côté que soit RTL lesgérard tout ça ça
m'a occupé pendant un moment j'imagine
en tout cas bravo parce que le résultat
est vraiment c'est formidable et ce que
j'aime bien de votre film c'est qu'il va
plaire enfin il plaît déjà à plusieurs
générations autant les enfants que les
ados que les trentenaires dont vous
faites partie évidemment et que les que
les 40 cant Nair enfin ça ça touche il y
a toujours quelque chose qui qui vous
touche finalement soit soit l'histoire
soit le côté Simpson voilà c'est
h ben bien pensé voula un truc qui qui
parle à tout le monde et je pense que le
le le l'idée d'un personnage ne pouvant
pas se débarrasser de ce qu'il est à
l'écran c'est un truc qui qui qui touche
quand même toutes les générations peu le
truc du morceau de scotch qui ou même
j'ai entendu des interviews de Peter
folk les gens l'appellent Colombo ouais
le gars n'a jamais réussi à se dépétrer
de son son personnage ce pauvre galass
même combat je pense que la voix de bug
Bunny aurait pu vivre une mésaventure
pareille mais pour l'instant
personne'avait eu l'idée donc
voilà bravo ouais super aidé et puis ben
écoutez j'espère pourquoi pas voir le
film en salle alors un courtmétrage en
salle bon al même si il y a une époque
où ça existait donc on peut toujours
rêveroui non non on peut pas rêver
marchant maintenant en cinéma c'est pas
possible on fera pas revenir des
courtmétrages au cinéma c'est totalement
illusoire à moins d'ouvrir des séances
spéciales et ben ouvrons des séances
spéciales on va demander au Tirano ah
bah qu'il fasse qui mais très bien très
bien très bien sera chette he je pense
que pour le coup là il y a une économie
à trouver d'accord mais écoutez on les
courmétrages avant les films c'est faut
terminer faut oublier ouais ça dépend
rien n'est impossible à versail mon cher
ami bon un grand merci un grand bravo
puis je vous laisse aller bosser parce
que heinou il y a du travail le temps
est con d'ailleurs je vais y aller hein
merci beaucoup à bientôt rentrez bien
merci au
[Musique]
revoir